cops use robots to defuse bombs confront
barricaded suspects and rescue victims
during disasters well what about all
those robots used to fight crime that
can do other stuff you know the ones
that can see record and track what
you're doing all day long
paranoid yet if not here are seven
creepy robots for cops number 7 is
smartypants streetlights yes the same
street lights now being tested in Las
Vegas could someday be set up to record
conversations from everyday passers-by
yep back in 2013 Las Vegas began testing
new streetlights that could play music
broadcast messages and potentially
listen to you don't we have a right to
privacy it's still unclear if the city
will purchase the lights but think about
your surroundings the next time you're
loitering with your friends or picking
up some dank marijuana from some dude
hanging out under a streetlight
number six is location tracking Wi-Fi
can you hear me now
no but I definitely know which street
corner you're on Verizon guy you may not
have noticed these white boxes mounted
on poles across Seattle you also may not
know these boxes can track you through
your cell phone in 2013 seattle
washington residents began to notice
curious Wi-Fi networks popping up on
their cell phones as available networks
to connect to you'll see these networks
named after intersections 3rd and union
4th and pike 4th and Union these are all
on the mesh network the boxes and Wi-Fi
turned out to be a wireless mesh network
set up by the city for emergency
personnel to communicate in case of a
disaster but privacy advocates said that
the network had the potential to track
your whereabouts as well think of
yourself as the Verizon guy he goes to a
lot of locations the Wi-Fi network
wouldn't just be able to know when and
where you showed up at the office but
also the desert the local swamp whatever
cold place this is or some wheat fields
somewhere can't hear me now piecing
together things you might not want local
cops to know about this one is for all
the nude sunbathers out there you know
who you are
number 5 is drums it's no secret that
police departments across the United
States are actively seeking to use
drones what isn't clear is exactly what
they want to do with them don't use
these types of devices for surveillance
California sheriff Gregory Ahern of the
Alameda County Sheriff's Department
backed off plans to purchase drones in
2013 because of public outcry then he
went ahead and bought them when nobody
was looking in late 2014 used to gather
intelligence from the scene of a mission
specific exercise out were deployed
yeah but what do you call a mission
specific exercise with the drone be used
for hunting criminals a bloodthirsty
murderer on the loose is a criminal but
so is a jaywalker where are the
boundaries for using a drone Oh
also because drones are cheaper to
operate than say a helicopter there's
every chance that a cop will want to use
that all-seeing flying robot for more
than crime-fighting and you can hear a
helicopter flying over backyard you
can't hear a drone so if you were nude
sunbathing and police drone flew over
your regard pictures of your butt cheeks
could end up being government property
number four is blanket phone tapping
hello Zack Morris is gone
mr. Belding would have done a better job
foiling Zack Morris's shenanigans at
Bayside High if only he didn't live in
1990s and get access to this
surveillance device stingray fools your
cellphone into thinking it's a real cell
phone tower thousands of records
belonging to innocent people can be
collected without a warrant you have to
imagine a world where everyone at
Bayside uses a cell phone that connects
to a tower but it sort of works like
this hello imagine Zack Morris is a drug
dealer at Bayside that the cops suspect
what I use dope they would park a truck
near the high school and then turn on
stingray to listen to whatever
conversation Zack had about dealing
drugs
the trouble would be that when they
listen to Zacks conversation they listen
to everyone else's conversation to know
meaning students at Bayside that had not
committed a crime would be spied on for
no reason someone should really watch
out for that Zack Morris - he's getting
everyone hooked on the junk
number three is see-through radar
remember the good old days when the
police would just know knock raid you or
enter house like Jack Torrance from the
shining those days are over get a load
of the range R a radar device that can
basically see through the walls of your
house yeah think about that the next
time you ignore someone at the front
door
an officer stands outside of the
building places it on a wall like a stud
finder inside your home and then sends a
signal back to him USA Today reported
that at least 50 US law enforcement
agencies have been using the range R and
you know gave little notice of the
public or the courts that they were
using them
at least you know when this guy is at
your door coming in at number two is
data-collecting beat cops
what are your prime directives serve the
public trust protect the innocent it's
being called a combination of r2d2 and
Robocop it's the night scope k5 and the
Silicon Valley company who makes it
promises to predict and prevent crime
with this little bugger designed for
security and police officers it will
roam around a pre-designated area and
alert authorities if something is fishy
sure k5 looks cute with its cameras
beeping and sassy attitude it can see
hear feel and smell but once you get a
load of its person tracking capabilities
you may not think he's so friendly
that's because k5 can send your location
to the cops through GPS and run your
license plate number think of k5 as a
messenger it has no weapons it won't
arrest people just pass along
information to local authorities we
recorded every word you said his
memories admissible as evidence that may
not seem like a big deal if you haven't
committed a crime but maybe you just
don't want your whereabouts known every
time you step outside maybe this is none
of the government's business where you
go on a day-to-day basis you're gonna
have to kill it
number one is the eye in the sky a great
eye lidless wreathed in flame no not the
all-seeing Eye of Sauron from the Lord
of the Rings but pretty close a lot of
people do have a problem with the you
know eye and the sky the big brother so
in order to mediate any of those kind of
complains we basically kept it a pretty
hush-hush that's sergeant dougie Kotani
of the Los Angeles County Sheriff's
Department and he's talking about
surveillance airplane tested by the
department in 2012 for nine days in 2012
a company called persistent surveillance
flew aircraft like this equipped with
cameras in the skies over Compton the
plane could fly for six hours at a time
and captured video of well everything
that happened in Compton California that
could be seen from above that's the part
of our Liberty come on now they took it
away you've been spying on us residents
didn't find out about the flying eyeball
until years after the fact it's the kind
of situation that makes you wish cops
would pay more attention to the kind of
power they have we do not know who else
may be watching
as with any robot used by the cops it
comes down to the officer using it did
they have strict rules for the robots
use and do they know when it's
appropriate to deploy although that's
all moot when the singularity happens
and the robots become aware and kill us
all have a good day